let's pull this story up right now yeah
let's go and uh
alex jones was right let me let let me
first give you some context we have from
yahoo news
government-funded scientists sought out
aborted minority babies for research i
mean on top of that it's racist what
i'm not even trying to make a joke about
this this is insane
researchers at the university of
pittsburgh received at least 2.7 million
dollars in federal funds to study fetal
organs
and attempted to retrieve half their
samples from the aborted babies of
minorities
according to documents released tuesday
again yahoo news
the national institutes of health had
overseen experiments on fetal tissue
at the university of pittsburgh since
2015 from aborted fetuses ranging
from 6 to 40 42 weeks
or two weeks past what is widely
considered to be full term
for the particular study in question the
grant request specified
that half the samples must come from
aboard fetuses of minorities
including at least 25 from
african-american women
according to documents obtained by the
center for medical progress and judicial
watch
let me just stress they say they were
studying fetal organs
they retrieved them from some babies up
to 42 weeks and they had the nerve
alex jones joe rogan war leads to
conspiracy theory meltdown
infowars host says babies harvested for
organs
now maybe that's a very extreme
interpretation of it what they're saying
is
admittedly not much better that the
babies had already been aborted
so you know by all means they can
experiment on that stuff but i'll tell
you this man i'll say i want to say two
things
first when the law allows a baby at 42
weeks to be
aborted then someone can go well better
not let the living baby go to
waste i'll tell you this if a baby is at
42 weeks and i'm gonna operate on the
assumption
you know i'm not going to give them the
benefit of the doubt that maybe the baby
was still born or something like that
it's
it's an aborted fetus at 42 weeks
they could have performed a c-section
and that baby is alive
so this is beyond the pale this is
something
i want to know what women were
carrying babies for 42 weeks
to get an abortion to give it to science
to use as a human guinea pig
like what kind of person carries a baby
for 42 weeks
could it could it have been stillborn
maybe like what the article said
i know i don't want to believe that our
country that universities that they're
funding this stuff
i want to i want to be like maybe it was
believe it man
i don't believe it stillborn is a type
of abortion involuntary
abortions yeah i mean miscarriages are
called spontaneous abortions sometimes
but
we're what we are talking about is
children who were being killed
intentionally
and then experimenting we know that a
hundred percent yeah well we know this
because
um there was an expose done of planned
parenthood back in 2015
where they went in with hidden cameras
and found that
higher-ups at planned parenthood were
negotiating prices
for the sale of fetal tissue and
in the footage they were saying things
like oh you know whoever throws a price
out negotiations first
loses in making jokes about the luxury
cars they wanted to buy it was really
obvious
that these people were selling this
tissue for profit
and what the media repeatedly said was
this footage is deceptively edited it's
not really happening
but the organization headed by david
deliden i should mention
was putting the full unedited footage on
the internet for everyone to see which
isn't what you do when you deceptively
edit footage
to try to trick the public now kamala
harris really went after him
and did everything she could to
prosecute him in california and then
very catholic joe biden
selected her to be his vice president
and as soon as he's in office
he repeals the trump era restrictions on
federal funding
for experimentation using aborted
children
that is our very catholic president that
is the devout administration under which
we live right now
now we got to be careful uh that story
planned parenthood was awarded a lawsuit
over that they they were awarded two
million dollars
i know i i i believe part of that was
he didn't have their consent to film
them i mean
they were very clearly negotiating and
haggling over the price
for these unborn children that they had
killed in order to sell them and
turn a profit on it is it that it was
edited to make it look like they killed
them but in
in fact they had been i mean it was it
was imported by the parents
it was planned parenthood right so what
they do is perform abortions and then
they were selling the tissue
after the fact i guess if mother asked
planned parenthood to abort the kid
who's the killer is it the mother or the
we don't
we we don't need to bring the story up
we have a new story right now can you no
sure sure my point is that this is
something we've known about yeah
well that the the issue there is if we
want this to be
clean and straightforward and be able to
tell people when you're sitting down for
dinner with your family members who
don't believe you
and you bring up that story they're
going to say oh they lost those people
lost that lawsuit they were liars
no we have a story right now we don't
need to bring up the past they're doing
this
we have documents that were released
they are buying this stuff i don't care
where they're buying it from
yeah no i think both stories are still
important uh in part because again the
full footage
is available online for people to watch
if somebody doesn't believe you i think
it's an easy argument to make
the crazy thing about this is it like i
i gotta i'm gonna
i hope your your kids aren't listening
my friends because
let me let me uh let me let me read this
all right for the particular study in
question
the grant request specified that half
the samples must come from aborted
fetuses of minorities as we read
projects funded by the national
institutes of health must ensure
appropriate inclusion of women and
minorities
they should also ensure distribution of
the study
they should also ensure distribution of
the study reflects the population needed
to accomplish the scientific goals
selden said that one of the goals is to
support researchers looking for
treatments and cures for kidney disease
which disproportionately affects
minorities zeldan all added that
research
researchers have no part in any
decisions as to timing method or
procedures used to terminate the
pregnancy
cmp founder and president david delayden
slammed university in a statement on
tuesday
the nih grant application for just one
of pitt's numerous experiments with
aborted fetus infants
reads like an episode american horror
story law enforcement and public
officials should act immediately
to bring the next next kermit gosnell to
justice under the law
the stuff that they were doing was uh
was was absolutely insane
i don't know where we had that oh yeah
so i had another story pulled up
that was talking about the grafting of
fat tissue but i guess i can't find it i
don't know did it get removed
all right i had a story pulled up um
about that here i
had some information about that here
that i can pull up that they were um
they were scalping five-month-old please
i mean
again for the faint of heart
they were scalping five-month-old uh
aborted fetuses to stitch onto lab rats
who said who is um this is i have it i
have this from music right here
oh okay gosh yeah it says in one study
published last year pit scientists
described scalping
five-month-old aborted babies to stitch
onto the back backs of lab rats
they wrote about how they cut the scalps
from the heads and backs of the babies
scraping off the excess fat onto the
baby's skin before stitching it onto the
rats
they even included photos of the baby's
hair growing out of the scalps
each scalp belonged to a little
pennsylvania baby whose head would grow
those same hairs
if he or she were not aborted for
experiments with lab rats now that's
propaganda it's a dead body it's not
hold on what do you mean that's
propaganda
that's a child stopping so someone right
i'm literally
someone chose to abort that child and
now if to call it a baby is disingenuous
because it's not difficult
and okay then it's a baby course and
they're so of corpse and they're sowing
its scalp to a rat well
it's a violation they find the infant
skin cells
are are good for like stem cells because
they're so young and vibrant i guess so
they use it like stem cell experiments
they use
infant that in no way just fetal
anything absolutely fetal
that doesn't that doesn't just it's why
they're doing it with those cells
particularly scientifically
i just don't i don't understand why it's
propaganda or how because they're like
if this child hadn't been then it would
have been a glowing baby
that's literally a fact how many weeks
are in five months
20 ish finding from newsweek
from 2015 finding that babies born at 22
weeks can
survive could change abortion debate
dude this 42 premature babies
can survive it's a 10 month abortion 42
weeks
that's insane i think i'm in the one
trimester camp and then after that i
think it's murder
i think it's alive i think it has a
brain i think it's a human but
in the first you know couple three
months it's still developing listen
listen listen it's a person i mean from
conception where else do you draw the
line
like when the brain is formed the thing
i find the craziest about this
is that this story is from may and i
write news
all day for two websites and i didn't
hear any of these details about it
but all day today i mean everybody was
outraged about fouchy killing puppies
which they should be right but why isn't
there the same outrage about
literal like full-term babies
like agree this is i mean we talk about
like that that infamous uh
group of japanese scientists that you
know they were recruited what was it
called
is that operation paperclip 37
fahrenheit
no no operation was it paperclip were
they uh paperclips where they brought
all the nazi scientists to the us
i believe that's correct um the japanese
camp there was a camp where they were
like units
47 i don't remember i'm sorry
yeah science is a brutal industry that's
for sure i mean they used to rip you
right
through extremely unethical like the
science has to be
restricted based on legitimate ethical
concerns
there are certain things you shouldn't
be able to do the the japanese
scientists would like take
a prisoner and stick their arm out of
the door like into the cold
and watch it freeze and then like
shatter it while the person was still
alive in the other room to see what
would happen to them
they say that um what we know about
frostbite largely comes from the
japanese doing research on live human
beings
that's horrible i mean people talk about
the nazi um
experiments like you know and rightly
condemn them pretty much across the
board
and then we're doing it here like we're
literally doing it in pittsburgh
well and it's crazy because people i
mean look
people are comfortable with things like
this happening as long as they never
have to think about it
they can know what's going on but if
it's not brought up then
they're able to sleep at night for
whatever reason and
i know that after
um for example you know the the uh
second world war i mentioned this
earlier my grandfather and his unit
marched all of the townspeople through
the camp to show them this is what
happened here this is what you allowed
we have unparalleled technological
infrastructure for communication
this information should be very easy to
get to people but the people who
have you know access to the gatekeeping
more or less
don't want the information getting out
there and so even when you do have
access to the information people will
shame you for discussing it so i know
that there are some campus organizations
and other pro-life groups that will show
people
what an abortion actually looks like
show people the aftermath of an unborn
child that's been killed
and people consider that to be evil or
cruel the act of doing it isn't evil or
cruel but showing people a picture of it
that's unreasonable
what matters is no one ever has to
confront what we're doing
we have to protect everybody's feelings
we have to make sure they don't feel
guilty
about what society is doing and about
what the abortionists are doing and the
fact that no one is standing up to stop
it
the real crime is showing someone that
they've supported evil
not the evil itself the important
clarification for the sake of all of the
fact checkers would be
people are getting abortions and then
doctors are buying the
the the fetus right we don't want to
conflate it that the doctors are
murdering the children and taking it's
like i don't know parents
but you are complicit if you know that a
child was aborted and you are
hold on let's let's let's try a
different way let's say that um
you're a researcher and you need fresh
corpses that
are you know from someone who died in
the immediate and there's a guy who
somehow just keeps happening to have
them all for you to buy
yeah you see the problem i have with
this is that
they they they lobby for a thing to
happen and then exploit the worst
aspects of it
in one of the most horrifying and
disgusting ways like
i don't i don't even know man i don't i
don't this this is
making me think of like a um industrial
animal slaughter
because they'll they'll not let people
see that stuff either
i got a problem with that too yeah but
also
they don't let you take photos of peta
ripping animals away from the
sanctuaries that they're in
and they have the court siding with them
and issuing gag orders on people
and um not allowing any filming
but and also in the big difference hide
their crimes
exactly well but i think there's another
point here to be made
because there's a significant difference
when somebody shows me
an animal being killed right in and of
course there are more and less ethical
ways to kill an animal but i can still
say
i believe that it's okay to kill animals
to eat them if you show me factory
farming i can say this is the wrong way
of doing it but no one says
it's cruel or inhumane or evil to show
someone who has eaten meat
what happens when you kill an animal in
order to get that meat
but it's considered cruel and inhumane
to show to people who are considering
abortion what abortion actually looks
like no i think people get mad at you if
you show them the factory farming
products
i think there are some people who will
get mad at you but generally speaking
people understand that
they're being provided with more
information i think most people
including people who eat meat
understand that factory farming is
really messed up it's really messed up
man i've been to the farms
where they have like the organic meat
and i was so impressed
i told i've told the story before where
the cows are just like the door is open
there's no gate and i'm like what is
this it's like
the cows are going to leave and the
farmer's like where they're going to go
and i'm like
anywhere and he's like like they got
food here and i was like wow
and so the cows are happy they live full
lives they have
food it's all automatic and the farmer
just lets them do their thing and then
i've also driven past the factory farms
where the ground is sludge and they're
all packed in and it's horrifying and it
smells i saw an undercover video at a
factory farm of one of the guys and and
what happens is people either they find
people that are already psychotic
no offense if you work at a factory farm
or people that are just willing to allow
themselves to be okay with murdering
and what they'll do is they train
themselves to see pig that means it has
to die and they'll they treat it like
like a piece of wood like they'll pick
up a baby and smash it on the ground
until it's
explodes its head and then they'll like
throw it in a pile and there's like
living animals screaming as they're
getting hit
they started passing these laws what are
they called like
you couldn't film the horrible things
they do like dude i'm
all about we're raising chickens i don't
know if we'll eat these ones because
they're the stars of chicken city so
they might
they might get you know a pardon but uh
we're raising a couple babies
and i got no problem eating the animals
and growing the vegetables
and we try you try and do it right you
know we're we're we understand
now uh some people don't eat meat
because they don't want to cause
suffering they don't want uh
you know for me i'm like well you know
i'll hunt and i'll eat but we're gonna
do it right we're gonna minimize
suffering of the animal and we're gonna
accept that this is part of
the life cycle but man i've seen some of
these videos where like a guy i watched
a guy like punta chicken
just for no reason no reason and i'm
like dude
it's because it's it's it's mechanized
it's just
shuffle them in they throw them in the
grinder and it's just
it's horrible man it's really horrible
stuff to watch
you know and uh i don't know what you do
in that regard
people are definitely willing to
tolerate that but i'll tell you when it
comes to
what they're willing to do to human
beings exactly it's like
why would i be surprised that they
horribly mistreat the animals who are
already living
horrible lives when you can see what
people are willing to do to each other
exactly when you look at what people do
to other human beings and it's no
surprise that we have this
unbelievably horrific warfare state
where people are
killed in other countries and the united
states government will either do it or
support governments that will go to war
and commit violence against civilians
like the saudi arabian government has
been doing in yemen
because if i don't have an obligation to
care for my own unborn child and it's
okay for me to kill them then why should
i care about somebody on the other side
of the world we need that
we will not have world peace for as long
as we have abortion we will not
we got uh i don't know i don't i don't
know what the root of this issue is i
know i can already hear many of the
leftists saying it's capitalism it's the
you know they cut costs they reduce
costs and i'm like i don't think that's
it
people people want and will eat meat and
you end up with these really nasty
situations and not to mention
what goes on with factory farming
results in infected meat and then they
put like what are they put like ammonium
or something
yeah in the beef because of the bacteria
serves it yeah
i tell you this you guys i have been
saying get out of the cities for some
time for a variety of reasons
yeah i've been talking about you know
growing your own food and raising our
chickens for a while now
where we live we can drive 15 20 minutes
and be at a farm
and there's one farm nearby it's like
self-checkout it's the craziest thing
i heard you walk in there's nobody there
and they've got like freezers with the
meat freshly harvested from like organic
field farm-raised animals and you walk
up you grab it you scan it you pay you
walk out nobody's even there i'm like
that's amazing
that's amazing you can see the animals
we went to one farm and
all the goats ran out and they were all
yelling at us and we were laughing and
the goats have this nice little area and
they're jumping up and down and they're
dancing at a good time and i'm like
they're living it yeah we farm that's
what we do but they're having a good
time
while they're here no i agree i agree
it's like um the luxury of like
european agricultural life being out
here
but with the value of the united states
like
uh product lines like you can order
anything
and receive anything by delivery but we
live like in this awesome
farm man there's a lot of people in this
country that don't care about anything
and that's what really bothers me
because we pulled up the polling data
the other day from civics
and saw that among democrat voters
they think the economy is doing fairly
good really good
and among independents and conservatives
they say it's fairly bad why because
those are the people that are in reality
and so i genuinely think like you know
you look at people who live in rural
areas who tend to be conservative
like they raise animals they take care
of their animals yeah not living in
cities where it's mechanized pollution
and waste and factory farming to get
enough food into those cities is very
very very difficult
i mean cities can be great for a lot of
reasons i know some people are like hey
stop bragging on cities and i get it
arts and culture can be fun
but the the difficulty in bringing in
resources into cities
it's crazy when you go to new york and
you see how you can't park anywhere
there's delivery trucks on every road
all the time because they got to get
enough food in for the massively tall
skyscrapers it is not an easy thing to
do
so they mechanize the process they
mechanize factory farms
they mass produce as much as they can i
tell you this dude when alex jones was
here is another thing he was right about
and he told me did you know you're
eating cloned beef and i said no we're
not
we're not eating cloned beef that's
crazy and then i googled it
yeah we've been eating cloned beef they
clone the animals
that is mind-blowing how awful all this
stuff is
i am a lifelong vegetarian and yeah are
you happy about it
yeah you've never eaten meat no i mean
look i got no problem eating meat i mean
before i was
three i think i did i saw bambi and it
screwed me all up
my parents indulged me thinking it was
the phase and my
stubbornness i just never ate it again
i'll tell you
the story as like uh are you vegan um
not currently i've went through you know
big like eight-year chunks of being
vegan with
you've been vocally supportive of animal
rights do you find that there's a
through line
with the abortion and animal agriculture
um i mean i think that it's all terrible
things that we're closing our eyes to
i think that factory farming is terrible
but i also i hate the animal rights
industry
also and anybody who's been following me
knows this very well
um my i think my current twitter name is
yeah
all my homies hate peter and i've
dedicated my life to now
destroying peta in any way possible i'm
going to be meeting with senators next
month
and i am working on a massive project
um including probably a documentary
about the evil stuff that they're doing
but people turn a blind eye to it
because like a lot of things
um you know you have like antifa who
claim that they're anti-fascist that
sounds so nice and lovely and we all
hate fashion it's terrible yeah
um peta people for the ethical treatment
of animals actually kill
more animals than a lot of these things
that they're fighting i mean they got
three chimps killed last year
they just seized six chimps from a very
lovely sanctuary that i went and saw in
person myself um
so i think that people are just
you know they like to think that they're
doing good people will donate to peta
without looking into the fact that
they've killed 75
of all animals that come into their
virginia animal shelter
and people will be like oh we're
pro-choice because women have a right to
their body and that's great and
wonderful
but they don't think about the cost of
any of those things they don't think
about what's really happening what these
organizations are really doing and
i think that it all kind of ties in
together in a way that we all just like
to look away from
terrible things being done this is the
non-profit industry you know
i i worked for these fundraising
organizations and
the reason they work is because you're
going to people and this is what i would
actually tell people
you are selling hopes and dreams you are
selling
absolvement of responsibility because
when we would go out we would fundraise
for the environment or force
any specific like advocacy we'd be like
hey you're busy we get it you can't
actively do these things so let us do it
why don't you pitch in it worked for
them too
that's right and so people would be like
make sense to me here's money
and then when i find out what they do
with that money i got really mad i end
up jumping organizations like
oh these people are bad and then i
realize hey wait a minute that group was
bad too
and then i realized wow they're like
most of them are bad yeah have you ever
seen poverty inc
no i would just recommend everybody
check that out it's sort of an expose
on the organizations internationally
that claim
that they're lifting people out of
poverty and through
you know foreign aid and charitable
works improving circumstances in
underdeveloped countries
but uh they're more or less in it for
themselves they don't really achieve the
results that they claim they're going to
it's a very good documentary it's been a
while since i've seen it so i wouldn't
be able to do it justice
in my summary but i would recommend
everybody check it out i was watching uh
rogan a little i watched rogan pretty
much frequently and he had a guest on
they were talking about the homeless
industry in california and they get
i don't know if it's billion is it over
a billion dollars a year um but what
happens is it goes to the executives of
these companies
that are supposedly taken care of and
they make six digits 250 000
salary 300 000 salary 400 000 so it's so
profitable for those people that they
don't want to fix
the problem as long as they're working
on the problem they're making banks and
this is why tom assault says
never put activists in charge of solving
the problem they make their money off of
a problem being there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time